hello welcome to honest trailer
commentaries the show where we talk
about that other show and then you come
watch this show I am especially a
Gilbert lon Joe dan today we're talking
about Shazam Sam if you haven't seen
this show before we're going to talk
about our thought process behind the
honest trailer we're gonna watch it all
together and add our thoughts and if you
stick around to the end you'll get some
cut jokes some deleted scenes and a clue
to next week's honest trailer mm-hmm
now we're already off to a great start
after moving this to a the screen
junkies channel because we said that we
were gonna do it on Wednesday so that we
could like respond to your comments and
your questions and like really interact
you know it's YouTube like let's talk to
the answer no no we're we're at Comic
Con now so I guess Dan maybe you'll play
the part of a whiney fan and and Joe you
can play the part of a someone who like
is really complimentary and I'll just
respond to your comments and questions
sure I already pointed out all the
problems with the trailer while we were
making it yeah maybe I'll find another
one in no point yeah we will be back to
pretending a listen to you next week
Shazam is a film that I enjoyed quite a
bit a lot yeah I think it's a really
good movie discuss I was dead wrong on
Shazam
I have to say when I first saw it it was
right before it came out luckily I got a
chance to see before it came out and I
came out of the screen and I was like
this movie is going to make so much
money I was like this movie is gonna
bridge Captain Marvel Avengers it is
gonna suck up every dollar no it didn't
I don't I like it a lot I guess I don't
know there's a signing or just it's it's
I like I really like this movie and it
did the worst out of all the DC movies
so did it should I know too many
expectations as to what I guess people
expect a DC movie to be at this point
he's not after Aquaman and Wonder Woman
oh yeah but I
also remember with this one like when
the first like set shots of Zack Levi
leaked online everyone's like Oh what in
the hell he's wearing like a dumb 90s
Captain America styrofoam mussels like
people work yeah we're so mad I think
the fact that they mixed in a lot of
comedy maybe gave people some hesitation
that was promoted so much as a comedy I
also just think it's a character that is
well outside the traditional Justice
League DC lineup that Warner Brothers
tends to go back to all the time yeah
but I just saw was guardians of the
galaxy or whatever and people showed up
for that then though Marvel had already
done a lot of the legwork of like trust
us like this Marvel you're gonna like it
even if you don't know it and I don't
know Marvel mortal engine was already
crazy you have to do first to trust is
good I trust them at this point I'm back
on all right like I will see a movie now
assuming it's going to be above average
I really like this movie say I don't
argue with me I'm just like I I do think
that there's something about like Shazam
as a character doesn't get people as
excited to go to the theater it's like
yeah I think maybe some people came to
expect from a DC movie a little extra
edge because even Jamie oh man James Wan
like gave that like a horror like edge
like it's like a MASH wrench and this
head so we talked about it this is head
some edge to it but I don't think it
maybe it was perceived as having that
edge and people sound like well if I
want to go see a jokey superhero movie
there's a lot of them out there so maybe
I can see them well this is little to no
darkness in it maybe visually but like
thematically it's really about like
family and you know it may have also
been the fact that it's centered on kids
and like a lot of DC fans are otherwise
cynical about I don't go see a kid's
movie and like did they not make it and
I want to see a grown-up movie about
Aquaman
DC tends to market the grit and the
darkness a bit more and I think that
they've cultivated that fanbase and this
movie was you know it's hard to stay
away from I'm making a kids movie about
Shazam though you know right Yuki
I like unless you want to go full
injustice and he's there I think it's an
X and now I want Marvel to compete with
this by going full old-school Fantastic
Four cartoon and having a little kid
that turns into the thing by putting on
a ring no ok and a floating robot yes
that is what I want for my fantasy Lord
every day should have their yeah yeah
let's watch the Australia for Shazam and
we'll try to remember to say pause when
we have something just because it's not
that they want to hear the trailer it's
that they can't hear us
oh we're taking that on board yeah ok
comment received
from the studio that's gone from doom
and gloom to fins and grins comes a
fun-filled ride for the kid inside
everyone
just maybe not actual kids and I don't
really have anything to say I just
thought we should pause I heard this as
a criticism again explaining perhaps why
it didn't make as much is that a lot of
people felt that it may have been aimed
towards kids but was too scary for kids
no this is a good toughening up kids
movie
I agree Goonies yeah but it's it's there
very clear lines of demarcation John a
lot now this is movies just for kids
this movies and I think a lot of people
are like I don't want to take my kids to
do this if they're gonna be scared yeah
one thing that came out after this open
I saw a lot of comments on social media
that were like there was no warning they
made it look like it was good for kids
and then it's super scary and my kids
were scared but it was pg-13 office oh
yeah pg-13 is the warning like me that
is the warning that like yeah it's gonna
be a little bit are maybe older kids you
know they'll drop one f-bomb yeah a
monster's gonna bite ahead yeah like
they did in my day kids we also I came
of age in the 80s when kids were just
like so yeah I didn't it was like the
Middle Ages like you were an adult at 30
or whatever and get out of the he wants
you Robocop bastard
remember in this movie the scene where
the bullies beat up his friend and then
he comes to the rescue and he never
showed up with the crutch 12 minutes not
knows punk you want to see the movie
about the white fluffy dragon we're
gonna kill a horse
dragon where they were gonna eat the kid
the whole first down I mean cannibal
orphan that's your price for animated
dragons that's how you get this
so exactly yeah I was like maybe it's
for the best let's keep watching yeah
meet Billy Batson he's got the street
smarts of Bart Simpson and the street
wear of Tyrone Biggums
that's a brilliant joke that Spencer oh
I gotta thank our super fan dizzle who
dresses up like Tyrone Biggums a couple
times right for a Comic Con I was like
he looks like dizzle and I was like wait
a second this is doing cosplay Biggums
the color yeah color it's like switched
sits like the red cap the black hoodie
with the black hoodie and the red yeah
it's gotta be I wish we could estimates
if I could ask David Sandberg one
questions like was that under yeah yeah
like to come up with a poll like that I
don't know is is amazing but also the
other thing I wanted to say here is that
we didn't we didn't get to play with
this in the trailer but it's I think it
kind of bugged me the movie can't decide
if Billy Batson is like really
streetwise or like kind of an idiot who
can't handle himself like the first half
he's like he's he's outsmarting the cops
he's like the ultimate street rat I got
it's all wired and then later he like
can't come up with like I was at the
business office like he's like a [ __ ]
he's like a kid he's learning the ropes
I guess
han Solo all comedy characters have to
be inconsistent or they wouldn't be
funny yes I ranch coat he should thank
his lucky stars he was born lily-white
movie by tricking some cops into a
convenience store something and then
closing the security grade on them and
stealing the cop car yeah and then like
a scene later the cop pulls that was
like you you took my meatballs in Philly
like nothing like some nice downtown
Philadelphia yeah David Sandberg did a
great video about like the difficulties
of making movies yes and rightfully so
and wilt wilt will share that we'll
share the blame on this taking of videos
like the ones that we produced the tasks
for sometimes not taking into account
how difficult filmmaking can be and then
pointing out mistakes and stuff but one
thing that he said was like sometimes in
these like analysis videos they'll give
credit to directors for like these deep
setup things and like subtle messages
that are only there because they just
had they couldn't get two actors hook it
up if you can't find it it's really
awesome it's one of that's what I wonder
if that's the example of what we're
doing like are we giving David Sandberg
in the costume department like credit
for an amazing deep cut Chappelle's Show
reference or was it just they was like
oh he'd have a code it's cold yeah yeah
I was so proud to be there when you had
your coffee cup drop moment yeah and
watch you have that realization in real
time we should now go back and treat
like it just Shazam look like Rick James
he'll show characters that they address
other characters in the movie that
caterpillars like after we defeat Shazam
I'll take you back to my house and make
you pancakes are the the extras in one
scene dressed like the player haters
ball
we just don't see it they're all
drinking a banana cognac gentlemen's
club good stuff all right
keep going Tyrone Biggums gets lured
into a cave by an old man who claims to
be a wizard which to be clear gets is
never a good idea as I pause again why
do they all have to be children he's
tending to his cave they were wouldn't
be like you're a grown man you seem like
a good guy it was marked strong in the
beginning when they're showing the
montage of people did they just know
that lady was an adult when it happened
makes it less cool it's cool it's it's
somewhat excusable if it has to be kids
and so he really has no choice but if he
could target anybody and he just chooses
to target kids more that's almost like
worse hmm to be fair to the wizard he's
casting a spell and the spell is Bree I
don't think he's the connection spoken
like a pause why did they just cast a
really old man to be a wizard like why
did they age up gemenon I think he's got
to be in your comic book movies now I
mean I guess but he is eternally he
eternally looks in his mid-30s and just
putting a Halloween store Merlin
bushy beard or just don't make him look
like a Merlin and just put a row bottom
and he's back but it's gotta be old yeah
he's gotta be old and he's gotta be he
doesn't have to be a guy grew a joke he
doesn't have to be a Gandalf style
wizard that's a choice to save me any
kind of old wizard they've opted for
that it's Dumbledore yes they had Ian
McKellen dropped out Diamond hounsou was
like town already on the set of a
different comic book movie was like I'll
be right there
you know and again like are getting back
to the directors video that he might
have been doing some other project it
was like you can't touch the hair and
the beard now true and beard already
grown he's like I'll play the wizard but
I can't touch the group for Santa Claus
for we're done shooting yet it is
macquaire he'll kick my ass they learn
not to CGI it out so there you go yeah
all right very good
the staff made him just a powerful sorry
you know he used to be called Captain
Marvel in 70s so because we're recording
this early we still have a couple of
little knit picks and lines and stuff
we're waiting for to get from John
Bailey so that line will be different in
the trailer that you get because we're
trying to avoid people criticizing us
the intent of the line is that they
switch the name from Captain Marvel -
Shazam in the 70s but the way it's
phrased makes it seem like he's a
character from the 70s they only call
the 70s and that we would then open
ourselves up to people saying like well
actually he was known in this camp which
we know but it was a very it was very
improper important word it word and open
there so and someone's wrong on the
Internet I don't know what's the nerd
version of the bat-signal
like like a horde like a 28 days later
horde
tell us we're wrong we don't need the
Fawcett comics community tears upset by
that that's sort of vague wording that
we chose to proactively change it so
that would be different in the version
that you seen enjoy it'll keep John he
used to be called Captain Marvel in 70s
but DC changed it to Shazam
that's Kazaam common mistake I mean the
guy obsessed with being worthy and
lightning no the street rat who gets
wish fulfillment powers wish fulfillment
free wishes to be exact
okay it's the one where Chuck flosses
om+ right yeah no I'm gonna floss this
back to your gums of truth we again
because we try to be very carefully we
try not to make mistakes but we kept
having to correct ourselves that Billy
was not an orphan right that's calling
him in or we said that we've got
wish-fulfillment powers but he's not an
orphan his mother is alive his father I
think was a little out of jail he's in
jail and so we would have been incorrect
if we preferred to him as an orphan I
was gonna bring this up later when we
talked about the mom abandoning him but
this movie does not reflect kindly on
the Philadelphia Police Department
because they find an abandoned boy at a
carnival his mother's 12 feet away and I
imagine the conversation went something
like hello boy what's your name where's
your mother
bring me a goose boy
I don't know what it Philadelphia that's
a father why did they never go to the
mom or dad's house to be like we found
your boy because he didn't know his
address Spencer you don't need to know
teach your kid their address they don't
want to abandon them and that was some
very shoddy police work on not finding
either of this boys living parents after
he was dropped off at a carnival
buddy might have called him like hey
that's my sister's kid now see I think I
think she was ready to boogie like way
before then like she had a go-bag block
away in Philadelphia right but wait I
know but just in case it didn't have
matter if it was the carnival or a
grocery store or whatever she's just
like at a moment you know I'd entity
it's possible that she had kind of given
him like they that they had located her
over the years but that she just didn't
want Billie backer he couldn't go back
to her cuz doesn't it seems like the
social worker kind of knows the story
and it's just like look maybe you should
just go with a foster family kid I'm
gonna give it to you straight at that
point yeah it's true the police were
busy because Bruce Willis was being
drowned in a puddle like a couple of
weeks for them yeah they're building up
to the shared universe crushes Bruce
Willis to death yeah I can't wait till
he dresses the rocking him wings mr.
glass into the atmosphere one hand
because AM joke came from I have lived
my life convinced that Shaquille O'Neill
played Shazam in the 90s oh and I I have
always thought that different film and
it was clearly differently obviously
Sinbad yeah
getting this right keep going gather
round for a heartwarming tale that out
families fast in the Furious you don't
meet time could also be construed as
pushing away his family if a superhero
can't save his family he's not much of a
hero thank you for this family if DC
said mom prayed a lot of sad moms in
this are happy if you choose to leave
you may never return I'm sorry I never
told you we didn't even include save
Martha nope didn't have to because
because oftentimes the conversation will
be how could you not include X and I
think the one that people would ask is
how could you not put save Martha in
that and that's really just a this goes
to editing sensibilities like that's
just a rhythm thing of just like every
one of those clips had arisen which is
like mom hero mom hero mom hero The
Watchmen because we talking about
Watchmen it's a DC adaptation even those
that DCE you say Martha was just it
broke the flow there's no mom in the
clip it's two men stew
just felt man plus I mean we've mined it
and they've had so who has in mind that
aside from same are there are some
conversations she's had with her son
that are on the grimmer side of like
maybe you shouldn't save yeah maybe I
don't know you squat I just feel like
the man we make a Superman joke later
yes yeah steel jokes have been mined by
us and others to death it's like let's
but no one talks about Watchmen so much
anymore it's throw know what oh you want
a dark mom story darkest darkest mom
timeline but I'm sure many will say yeah
and it is interesting though that like
Marvel's go-to is you have a distant
abandoned or abusive father DC of a
distant abusive or abandoned mother you
know someone should looking at
interesting anyways keep going
as Billy learns that family isn't about
who abandoned you at a carnival on a
whim it's about there you're forced to
live with who love you because you're
constantly saving their asses for
Possley we can talk about like his
family his sidekick gets a character
gets development but the whole all the
other foster friends are just it's like
I'm this one note I'm this yeah and
we're all in peril videogames you know I
feel like some of it is laying the
groundwork for well in future movies we
would get more of that side of things
and I think a lot of it is about the
third act twist that you got it you got
to lay the groundwork that let's just to
establish eyeball eyeball man and Shazam
and the whole mythology around being a
wizard supporting character can be the
sea captain from Raiders of the Lost Ark
for me they're like man and three lines
they really nailed that backs tense
great Twitter thread about this yeah
real quick as it was really good looking
up he talked about how very quickly
Spielberg and Lucas managed to give you
such rich detailed lives for all of
Indiana Jones supporting characters like
all these guys like jock and Solow who
show up for like one scene but it all
feels like they have such a rich
backstories and that's it's so hard to
do it seems those movies we could feel
effortless but when you see something
like this you realize when you've only
got a few moments with the character
it's really hard to get a fall back on
cliche yeah it's really hard to give
them a whole lived in realistic fleshed
out backstory
yep I want to know the backstory of
those parents were they're like we want
one of each type of like Pokemon
trainers like there's something weird
yeah I thought that's where the movie
was gonna go before he's like I'm just
screwing with you and he was like they
seem nice but they're awful I was like
oh okay
you're just ads foster parent for the
sequel alright let's get go but Shazam
will have to fight more than just the
overburdened foster care system he's up
against dr. sivana a veteran character
actor out for revenge on DC for casting
him as Sinestro and Green Lantern watch
him and leash the power of the seven
deadly sins each its own representation
of a different human failing with unique
powers that actually no never mind bombs
they just eat people
man the rock can not get here fast
enough doesn't really have to be about
the very angry caterpillar I said when I
saw this in the theater it started twice
there's literally like the same reaction
in both theaters which is like 99% of
the people they think they're going like
yeah then like I don't know anybody am i
screening a lot of us were like brain
yet but he's put himself into a world
that was the leading theory when I died
in a room for the critics like I didn't
even see it in like normies regular
regular civilian movie guy has no idea
what that what that was no and if you go
over for in this table I mean just look
at us and although it doesn't remind me
of when we saw Avengers that was the
reaction for Thanos look at the cusp of
my understanding I was like oh that's
Thanos yeah but no way am I getting cat
a caterpillar yeah what's amazing is if
you look into it there are a lot of
references to the monster Society of
evil in the movie which is mr. mine the
caterpillar is like evil group like the
crocodile men are also part of the month
yeah so if dr. sivana later joins it so
like they're definitely leading into
Shazam's rogues gallery people just
don't know but what I thought it was a
done deal that the rock is gonna get his
solo movie yeah I mean they even set it
up in this one where they're like we
picked a previous champion but he failed
us I think that's so close to be the
rock I got it and then the caterpillar
it's probably gonna be a like Shazam and
black out of start fighting and then
they they become Fred's on a white board
yeah you meet Cochise at first you think
he's a terrible guy like they're doing
that thing keep going
well I Rock can't make friends ourselves
in cinematic enemies just can't yeah
sorry attend your along SDC finally
cracks the code on making a heartwarming
fun inspiring movie about an invincible
strong man a super man if you will that
gives kids everything they dream of no
not turning into a 38 year old and a
Styrofoam muscle suit no not terrorized
I think is he worth now your life a
living pause he really did man how
annoyed are you if you got ripped
because he did he got ripped for this
and then they're like you're going in
the muscle suit into you they make it a
running gag that he can't get the suit
off so he can't possibly show off his
abs yeah yeah be mad be so man who do
you think didn't did he show up just
like not buff enough I think it's a
child's it's it's supposed to be such an
elevated child fantasy that I think it's
just like they already have and Plus
that you already have Superman you
already have the hustle guy in the
muscle suit like Shazam is so much like
you're gonna have to go like Hogan
Ultimate Warrior in the 80s level they
gave Chris Pratt
but even Pratt's not like Travis lanky I
mean if he was lean like Shazam you
gotta be like it you gotta be like a
tank alright well have Batista give you
some of his there's something on the DL
or something like that mark the Marvel
guys they take that HGH dude for the
nois Antonio playing he-man that's what
that's who I'm worried about he's got to
have his shirt off I don't know
whose no incentive give the keys for my
call those like Netflix Rock it's like a
little lengthy 18 year old kid he's
gonna play and then Adam she's just
Shazam's into some bodybuilder and then
they dub his voice and you could beat
him up yeah I guess cuz animation was so
cheap in the 80s but that's what I never
got about he-man and Prince Adam was you
know he was still a bodybuilder and he
was Prince Adam he should have been like
a really lengthy dude yes but that's an
extra character you have to animate
because it an extra action figure
because it's about I guess they made but
it's about toxic masculinity ban because
everyone in Eternia was like there's no
way our champion would wear that pink
and purple t-shirt - no it's not even a
costume it's just credibility more than
Superman it gets because it's like the
David Sandberg thing I'm sure there are
many hours of philosophy is why that
it's because they would run on the same
loop the background every other yeah but
still it's not that hard in my head game
it's just when he man pops his shirt off
there's no way you're looking in his
eyes like you don't yeah you're just
lost
I lost man for who he is so I will
looking man under the eyes if you ever
met he-man you would look in the eye
earned your respect his power is in here
I don't cower by his pecs the real power
was his mind I'm watching Shazam we
could talk about this moment if you
rolled in a styrofoam muscle suit no not
terrorizing the boys who make your life
a living hell I'm talking about a kid's
ultimate power fantasy developing story
you're a wizard Billy it's gonna be in
the final cut yeah Jack Dillon grazer
this is a great kid performance yes like
he's teeth he's a lot of the energy that
keeps the movie sort of going why why
did the staff call that kid he's great
yeah but he's not you know he the power
would not he would go to his head yeah
you had to learn not to be quite a punk
that's fair yeah I also think that they
kind of made it like a emotional beat
between the two of them that like Billy
was like you're just jealous yes he's
jealous of you that's actually you
should understand that I felt bad for a
sure angel in this movie cause like Jack
Dylan grazer got to do like all the
funny comic relief's none and Zachary
Levi got to do like all the way like
fighting stuff and like ash angel just
like he was really good but like he just
had to be sad like that was his role
look like he got to be sad and then say
Shazam and turn into a hero and it's
like he was really good in the movie but
like he just didn't get like the show he
rolled be fine his name is Asher angel
you have to
model and boy actor staff calls for all
after angels like slightly less talented
the idea though that like all these
amazing things are happening on set and
like there's explosions to his left on
his right and this kids like Shazam cut
all right Zack said when they're getting
his muscle inflated it's like alright
how does this II work out is like okay
Zachary Levi is gonna fly around this
bullets are gonna bounce off of okay
he's gonna save this thing from a ferris
wheel and then you get drowned you pop
your head up out of the water and you
say Shazam and the sack really lights
gonna come in and save the day cool so
you're just gonna come in here and we're
gonna hold your head underwater
I have no sympathy for anyone named
Asher Angels got that name of Tiger Beat
[Laughter]
all right let's give my favorite boy
band for me with me whispered at this
day this script drafted before the
recent like a week before as a news
broke yeah yeah but still of the never a
good time to know my house I mean when
the movie was in theaters and I saw it
and they say I believe in I can fly like
four times was like let's see if I can
fly oh yeah little tweak yeah never a
borderline issue with us it's just like
should we like no we're confident that
won't conjure any uncomfortable
references right no it just angel
what's-his-face just being like it's a
remix to ignition
I like to have sex in the kitchen rolls
that's a non-sequitur
make a live-action gargoyles bubble you
cowards can't be done with bossing now
please yeah shows the sprayer is amazing
how did this reference pause the sad
thing is I said something like to old
for the Internet get us off of here it's
just replaces all with a stranger Little
John is now like old man music it really
is like that's like way too old for
music some more boys to take the step
from us the next generation of honest
trailer riders have yet to come and
claim the staff so we're gonna keep
sitting on our empty stone Thrones throw
in 2003 music references at you and so
you drag us out of this building by our
cold dead arms made at least one Old
Town Road reference for another five to
15 years we're carrying with it
[ __ ] Hopi I miss doing too much work
Sparky in Philadelphia okay this is the
second DC film with an Annabelle cameo
so the conjuring definitely takes place
in this universe but teasing us with the
Cameo is already in an Aquaman punch the
none of the face okay yeah I like John's
big dick indignant voice yeah good
performance by John let's see what
wasn't funny enough to make it into that
yes
meet Billy Batson boy with the power out
of be white shoulda gone in it's like
it's a funny joke but it feel like it's
if you have to explain you have to
explain what happened where he stole a
cop car and the guys lunch and then the
guy catches him and instead of shooting
him several times that's what you would
expect a Philly cop to maybe sir
anyways too much we've already explained
it's a lot it's exactly they already not
funny yeah so there you have explanation
of it yep and story Billy the Kid all I
knew versus IRL you possibly be met
about area when they made Santa black
eye actor mark strong kid vicious
subscribe from posting OC to post OC
Foster's Super Friends not always series
sometimes you just throw stuff out guys
birds
by my day I really like there's more
that's it begins takes no time you'll
see we didn't even give ya call you by
my name also there's my favorite that
was between those two it does require
some explanation though because it's
like you're using the name of the wizard
to invoke should you become a hero who's
named after the wind ranted you the
power it also makes for weird Wikipedia
you have to be like Shazam parentheses
wizard yeah if you knew the show by now
you see why they're deleted and why
they're in the trailer because there's
not much to say about them that that's
our gold everything no but I'm glad you
guys got to see that anything else about
Shazam before Wheaties next week alight
I really I really like this one i I'm
hoping that DC does more like this like
just take the character on its own terms
think about what kind of genre and
presentation would work best for that
character and not worry about how
they're gonna interconnect although it
is too bad cuz like I would watch a
Shazam Superman team up or Shazam and
Batman or I found myself getting very
excited when he was like I called
someone else for lunch and I was like it
was like off shot and I was very
actually very disappointed because yeah
I want to cavil there they really it
made me really want cavil they're good
Superman and it would have been really
fun to see him in this definitely well
there you have it I hope you enjoyed the
honest trailer commentary first as I am
and I hope you'll join us next actual
Wednesday where we will actually be
responding to what you have to say about
next week's honest trailer mm-hmm which
I believe will be the you know someone
coming back it'll be the return of an
old favorite mm-hmm yeah so there you go
definitely that's your clue and thanks
again for watching we'll see you then
bye Mike
[Music]
you